trouver une solution rapide pour contrer
la pandémie de coronavirus un objectif
majeur pour plusieurs laboratoires voir
des structures étatiques comme
l'institut gamaleya de moscou vladimir
poutine a annoncé cette semaine au
développement par les experts du pays
d'un vaccin efficace nommé spoutnik v
celui ci serait actuellement en phase
finale d'essais cliniques
le locataire du kremlin a précisé que sa
propre fille avait participé à
l'expérience en se faisant inoculé le
sérum le ministre russe de la santé a
indiqué que le vaccin serait destiné
dans un premier temps en soignant avant
d'être mise à disposition des
volontaires
de leur côté les états unis ont misé fin
juillet sur le duo pharmaceutique sanofi
et gsk un investissement de plus de 2
milliards de dollars pour tenter de
bénéficier d'un vaccin anti copie de 19
le plus vite possible
le contrat en question prévoit la
fourniture de 100 millions de doses à
destination des américains dans le même
temps l'union européenne a décidé de
réserver 300 millions de doses du même
vaccin
le royaume uni s'est arrangé pour
recevoir 60 millions d'unités région du
monde la plus touchée par la pandémie
l'amérique latine s'activent elle aussi
pour tenter de trouver des solutions
cette semaine l'argentine et le mexique
ont annoncé un compromis afin de
produire le vaccin du laboratoire
astrazeneca entre 150 et 250 millions de
doses seront fournis aux pays concernés
à l'exception du brésil en fonction des
résultats des tests prévus pour la fin
de l'année l'objectif est de livrer la
version finale au premier semestre 2021
d'après les argentins cette combinaison
du privé avec en prime le fait que ce
vaccin sera vendu sans aucun profit
signifie que nous pouvons le faire
rapidement que nous pouvons le rendre
bon marché et accessible à tous la
vérité est donc que ce projet a que des
avantages et des choses à nous apprendre
aussi pour l'avenir
en février nous enverrons là bas les
antigènes produit ici les principes
actifs et là aussi le remplissage prend
du temps le vaccin doit être distribuée
il doit être approuvé par les autorités
je pense que ce sera davantage aux
alentours du milieu du semestre
disons que c'est ce que nous visons la
phase 2 a eu un taux de réussite de 91 %
ce qui est très élevé
et avec deux doses il atteint 100 % ce
qui a donné à tout le monde l'espoir de
pouvoir dire allons de l'avant en
prenant des risques
en asie la chine test un vaccin en
indonésie depuis plusieurs semaines le
gouvernement indonésien qu'on produire
250 millions de doses près de 1600
volontaires participent aux essais
cliniques de phase 3 qui devrait se
poursuivre encore pendant plusieurs mois
d'ici janvier 2021 nous prévoyons de
produire entièrement les vaccins ici
nous sommes prêts nous les distribuerons
à tous les habitants du pays
on veut pouvoir vacciner toute notre
population c'est difficile de créer son
propre vaccin c'est pour cela que celui
ci nous l'avons achetée
en mai dernier l'agencé européenne du
médicament avait estimé qu'un vaccin
pourrait être disponible d'ici une année
dans un scénario qu'elle juge optimiste
d'après l'organisation mondiale de la
santé
sur les 167 projet lancé à l'échelle du
globe
seuls 8 serait en cours de finalisation